Android
and iOS. We can definitely do another session
on this shit. Yeah.
Are you on a what are you on?
IOS or Android? Did So I was iOS
for the last six years. I was Android
fully before that, and now I'm back on
the Android train. And I've gotta say the
Pixel is a great device.
Yep.
Oh my gosh. Like, I can go on
so much about the whole iOS because I've
done both. I was a iOS,
like,
iOS user for a long time, then went
went to Android,
then went back to iOS, and, like, currently,
I'm on Android on a Pixel device and
loving it. Absolutely loving it. Yeah.
The only thing I really miss is just
the Pixel watch is dreadful.
But the Apple watch Yeah. I have I
have one. Like, it's a
whatever. I never had an Apple watch, so
I don't know any better. But the Apple
watch is great because you we're able to
just, like, log in to my MacBook with
it and everything, and I've lost all that
convenient stuff. But, I mean, I'm willing to
pay that price for a more open platform.
Yeah. Well, in part of that, it's because
you're on a you're on you're on Linux
too. So Yeah. Ironically,
Android works better with Windows.
Yeah. That that's that's
yeah. That's what I want.
Yeah. The the integrations there are stellar.
Yeah. People are dripping in the hello, BigPod.
Says echo. Is that me?
Do I have an echo?
Oh, shoot. Someone
I'm not hearing anything. Yeah.
And there's some iOS ARCs. That's nice. Yeah.
I mean, this is just gonna be a
therapeutic run, I think, from the three of
us. Right? So Yeah. So, Hayden, I wanted
to know yeah. So I think so
I guess if we all just,
like, basically shared, like, what what we work
on or whatever. But, like, Hayden, I've never
quite figured out. Are you primarily a Windows
user? Like, your breadth of knowledge on
Linux use
Linux and Unix
and Windows is amazing.
And, like, I can never really figure out,
like, what type of user you actually are.
I mean, I I use both daily.
So daily driver,
Windows 11 with WSL,
but I work in the cloud. I work
on my own servers on Linux.
I mean, I've used Linux
since, like, I was a teenager since, like,
circa 1999.
Like, my first Linux experience
was having to rebuild the Linux kernel to
support my ATI graphics card.
That was my first foray into Linux. This
is like it's almost the same because I
got into Linux around '98. It was around
the time Windows '98 because, like, I was
I was I got into computing or whatever,
like, was really with DOS, pretty much just
Intel and DOS. That's where you know? And
so I I got heavily into Windows '95.
I was very active in the wear scene
back then. Nice. And so I got into
Windows 95 really early because it was all
on the wears. You can get it early
before it came out. So I I, like,
I got into Windows 95 and got super
good at that. And then by the time
Windows 98 came out, I was, like, fed
up with like, I could reinstall Windows
so fast and reconfigure everything because I felt
like I had to do it weekly because,
like, it would just always go to crap.
So I'm like, there's gotta be something better.
So I started looking at Linux.
And so my experience with with Linux was
like, I'm like, oh, I heard about this
thing. Let me download it and try it
out. And I spent literally about a month
trying to get the Tulip driver working for
my network card.
And
but, by the way, also realized I knew
nothing about programming. Really nothing. It was like,
I spent about two weeks just trying to
get Linux installed,
and then I finally got it installed. And
I got it, like, boot up, and I
got to the command line. Like, I got
to the login,
and then I'm like, shoot.
I didn't because, like, Windows doesn't have a
user by default. It was like I was
like, what do I log in with? So
then it was like, I had to find
out what a root user was and what
the root user.
So I actually
came up on early DOS, early Windows,
started dabbling in Linux.
And then
post XP,
I kind of still fiddled with Linux
but
switched to Mac.
And I was pretty diehard Mac user from
about 02/2003
to I can date it to
the new
MacBook butterfly keyboard.
Yeah. So I I I bought I I
sold my old MacBook Pro and bought the
new MacBook Pro every year
until the butterfly keyboard came, and I could
not stand it. So I started looking around
for great keyboards,
and I got a lot of recommendations for
ThinkPads. And I'm like, perfect. I'll get a
ThinkPad. They're really well supported on Linux,
installed Linux,
but there were a handful of applications I
needed at the time that needed Windows that
didn't run well in Wine, and I was
running VMs.
And this little thing had just been announced
just around 2016
called WSL.
And I'm like, wait. So I can have
a desktop
that just works,
runs all my programs,
but then also gives me my Linux working
environment for programming.
And
that's that was it for me. So,
David, I think we before we went live,
you commented how
you wanted a OS that
just worked but still gave you that
that that experience on the terminal.
I just came at it from a different
direction.
Yeah.
Like, David, what are what are what are
you running now? So
I'm in a bit of a weird phase
right now. So after the fire, I just
stole my my Apple hardware.
I'm kind of in frustration with the Apple
approach to the the European ruling that they
had to have a more open platform, and
I feel that the way they made App
Store to work in Europe only and super
expensive, like, the paper install and stuff like
that. I was just like, this isn't the
company I wanna be using
their products anymore.
So right now, I have a nice desktop
computer.
I've got a new Android phone, and the
Linux that I'm running is normally Nexus,
which I know I'm gonna get slapped for.
You're just playing into a.
It's the boss. The form you you listen
to to Twitter too much of everyone who
everyone who's talking about these days is, like,
just dive right into.
And in my opinion, Nixos is what I
was running, like, seven years ago before I
went on my Mac my Mac holiday. So
but
I am trying for Dora Silverblue right now,
and I'm gonna kinda try and explain why.
I've given talks at conferences over the years,
and I talk about my desktop habits or
laptop habits, which is I wipe all my
devices every 30.
Cool.
Because I like the automation. I like to
know that I'm never losing anything older than
a month.
Keeps me fresh. I change things up.
But with SilverBleu, I don't know if I'm
even gonna need to do that because it's
an immutable operating system
where I just have my home directory. And
everything that I need, I I still use
Next. Like, if I need packages, I use
Next or Flatpaks.
Flatpaks are a pain. We'll get into that
as we kinda
go through the flow the flow of the
motions here.
But I'm really impressed with Silverblue.
It's essentially code OS,
but for desktop computing.
And George, who was on the chat don't
know if he's still here because he says
he'll need to catch up with the recording.
He has a a uBlue. He works on
the uBlue project, which is, like, trying to
make it silver Silver Blue more developer friendly
and for it went to expatriates. I don't
even know what that means, but it comes
with some pretty awesome default. I don't understand
that either too.
What
what exactly is the Ubuntu flare that that
they're adding? But
but it's a no. I like what they're
doing with the
Yeah. It's it's just it's the simple things
that, like you know,
I normally disable Secure Boot, which I know
I get flagged for too.
But they make it so easy because they
handle all the signing and stuff like that
that it just works. Yeah. And they even
configure things like using the TPM module for
automatic disk decryption.
And, like, it's all these subtleties that just
make it a more pleasant experience. And, also,
the fingerprint reader works on my framework laptop,
which is never the case. And I don't
know what magic they've done to their configuration
to make that work, but I love it.
Yeah. They're doing a great job. I think
that's more of a testament to framework because
they they cater so much to the Linux
community. Because, like, I would use the fingerprint
reader on my my ThinkPads or whatever, but
it just wasn't reliable enough. Kinda drove me
nuts. Yeah. Yeah. Not in this weird situation,
Marie. You're scanning it. It says no enter
password, and then you start typing your password,
then the fingerprint logs in anyway. And you're
like, what?
Yeah. All these little things.
And Yeah. Yes. Framework is amazing. Their their
hardware is great. Like, I just ordered a
new released a new screen, and I can
hot swap that. This well, not hot swap.
But I can swap it pretty easy when
it comes, and I'm like, this is amazing.
So Yeah. So I have a serious problem
when it comes to buying laptops. I almost
always buy a new laptop every year,
and then it's, like, kinda gotten worse these
days because, like, I started getting into, like,
Windows and AI stuff. So then it was
like, oh, well so I, like, I have
a framework.
It's like, I'm a I've been a pretty
diehard
ThinkPad user,
and then I got into framework because I
like the fact you can swap out things.
I think, like Yeah. Framework's kind of like
promise, ThinkPad's
my impression like, I really like ThinkPads. I
just think they're such a nice like, when
you think about a laptop,
it's like, what do you care about a
laptop? It's it's like the tactile experience of,
like because that's the thing you're physically touching.
So you should get the one with the
best keyboard with the best feel or whatever.
So it's like that's why I like the
ThinkPad so much. So, like, framework is kinda
weird. It's the op it's somewhat it's like
it's more practical. It's swappable. It's all those
stuff, but it doesn't have the same, like,
tactile experience, but it's not terrible. It's just
like so it's like it's a weird thing.
But, anyway, so I have a framework.
Like, I have a framework, and then in
the last, like, month or like, last month,
I guess, I got a Surface laptop.
But even on the framework, was running Windows.
But
but, anyway, so let me let me explain
my my my setup or or whatever. Like,
what I what I do. Because, like, I
I got in like I was saying, I
got into Linux back, like, in in the
late nineties,
and I I mean, I'm a diehard Linux.
Like, I just 100%
switched to Linux. Everything I've done
since then has been all of my personal
and professional
devices have always been Linux. Like, every company
I worked at never allowed Linux, like the
big companies I worked at. Mhmm. But I
just broke all the policies and hacked my
way and figured out and I always ran
Linux. I did a lot of, like, terrible
things where it's like, oh, like, that was
probably not a smart idea, but I was
young and stupid. But, anyways, so it's like
so I've always run Linux on everything. So
it's like, my my perspective is, like, one,
I love Linux because
I have this thing where it's like, it
just drives me nuts where it's like, I
want things to be a certain way.
Like and if I can't have that, it
drives me nuts. I think it's just like
my aversion to authority or something. You know?
It's like, I just so that's what drives
me nuts about Mac is, like, Mac is,
like, an amazing thing, but there's just certain
things that are just like, no. I you
just can't have that. Like, you just can't
have it. And so that's why, like, fundamentally
why I just will not use Mac. It's
like that I I'll run into one thing
that would drive me nuts, and I can't
have it, and I just can't work around
it. There's no hack. Whereas, like, Linux, Windows,
there's always a hack. But, anyway, so it's
like
for Linux,
it's like, I've been using it so long,
and I went through basically the kinda like
the first fifteen years of using Linux was
more of your typical Linux person who, like,
thinks it's amazing and wants everyone to use
Linux.
And then after about, like, fifteen years, realized
how kind of dumb it is to, like,
preach Linux to people. And then, like, for
the last decade, it's more like, okay. I
just need this thing to work. And I
and I just, like so I'm, like, I
I now on Twitter is, like, I'm just
constantly telling people how terrible Linux is.
Yet, like, I'm a diehard Linux user, but,
like, I just can't help because it's, I've
used it for so long that it's, like
there's just so many problems of, like, trying
to get it to a larger mass market
of users that, like, it's just so infeasible.
And so it's like I don't know. On
the one hand, it's like I don't wanna
discourage people from trying to make Linux better,
but on the other hand, I understand, like,
the practicalities
of it will probably never get across the
line. Like, it'll probably like, it's so hard.
Like, Canonical had the best shot, and they
gave up. And so I was like, I
don't know where Linux like, how Linux is
really gonna so it's like, it's just this
niche niche niche thing. But
but, yeah, that's, like, the bigger but, like
but for me, like, for Linux these days,
it's like, it just has to work. That's
my biggest thing is, like because I use
it professionally and I do everything. It has
to work. So I I go towards I
have a very kind of conservative Linux
approach
that, like, is not shiny and cool. Like,
everyone like, everyone who's trying to get to
use Linux these days is doing, like you
know, it's like, oh, look. Like, this crazy
team up set up or or
or
whatever. Or
Like,
all the stuff that, like like, you know,
DHH is doing, which is great. Like, I'm
glad to see bringing users and new exciting
thing or, like, all that stuff. I don't
do any of that. I'm, like, a really
boring user.
I don't know. Like so I wanted to
actually, like like, show completely, like, show my
setup.
Like like, this is how I use Linux.
So it's like, this is how I use
Linux. And then why over the last, like,
six months or so, I've actually switched to
so what I have is, like, I have
a desktop and a laptop. My desktop is
this crazy Threadripper system
that runs Linux.
It's static. It's like the workhorse.
And then I have a laptop, and I
flip, like, fifty fifty between the the the
two things. So it's like during the day,
I'm working on the desktop, and at night,
I'm working on the laptop. And I typically
do more programming on the laptop because at
night, I'm not talking to people. During the
day, I'm talking to people.
And so
my setup is, like, I have, like, a
I synchronize things between the devices so I
can very seamlessly go back and forth be
between me or whatever. But so it's so
the the desktop is Linux, but the laptop
is Windows.
And I'm able to switch between the two
and and really not know any different. And
that's what I've really enjoyed about Windows and
WSL two is I get my, like, Linux
fix out of it
because the way I've I use it and
the way I've set it up is, like,
I almost don't even know it's Windows. I
really
rarely see the Windows side of it,
but I get the benefits of the Windows
side of it where things generally just work
better.
Like like, for example, like, I tried to
join a Google Meet for this this like,
the invite you sent out had a meet
for something that I Google.
So I clicked that.
And, like, when you log in to that,
it was like, oh, do you wanna have
us frame your your like, use AI and
frame your your head in the picture or
whatever?
So I'm like, oh, that's interesting. Let me
click that. Complete garbage. It's, like, slow. But
this is the thing you just come to
expect on Linux. It's like, ah, whatever. It's
like it's Linux. Like, it probably works fine
on Mac and Windows. But, like, on Linux,
there's some weird thing where it's just not
working right or whatever.
So
I don't know. So,
yeah. So let let me let me actually,
like like, share my setup. I'll show you
what I'm doing. So, like, I'm I'm sharing
my screen, and I'll show you. Let me
get this out of the way.
So this is gonna be, like, tiny because
it's just, like, my my desktop or whatever.
Let me let me oh, yeah. I'll just,
like, minimize this. Okay. So what I run
so this is my desktop. It's like what
I run is
Ubuntu.
Oops.
Sorry. That was me. My bad.
So
so what I run is I run Ubuntu
LTS.
So, again, like, what I found is
I really hate rolling distributions
because rolling distributions, they just end mean in
the Linux ecosystem, a rolling distribution just means
you're gonna randomly break.
And so for my host OS because, like,
I really separate things between, like, what's the
host OS and then what I have in
my home directory. For my host host OS,
I want something super stable.
So it's like, I really like Ubuntu LTS
because Ubuntu, what I found, it has, like,
the best compatibility with hardware from a kernel
perspective.
Like, Fedora, I think, is an amazing distribution.
Like, they're doing a lot of good things,
but it still does not have the the
compatibility,
I think, that that the Ubuntu kernel does.
Like, I, like, I think Ubuntu puts a
crap ton of effort into just hardware device
compatibility and whatnot.
So
so, anyway, so I run LTS, and so,
like, I haven't even switched to twenty four
zero four yet because I was it was
more of, like, I'm gonna hold off and
wait till that stabilizes a little bit because,
again, I don't wanna be screwing too much
with this. But so so what I run
is
Some some of their motorcycle or something.
So
I
this is ex Ubuntu, but I think I
technically install Ubuntu
because, like, I'll do an Ubuntu, a minimal
install, and then just do the x
the x debt or x Ubuntu desktop package
or whatever. Whatever. But but for the most
part, like,
the packages that I have installed on the
host are
are just ex Ubuntu. Like, I don't really
actually touch app that much. Like, I I'm
a pretty diehard like, I use brew for
pretty much everything.
So it's like, I use brew in my
home directory.
Because, like, what I found over time was
that, like, if you keep your host OS
super stable and you never touch it, like,
you it needs to supply, like, the base
graphical environment. So x f c x f
c e comes from it.
Like, I keep that super stable,
and then I have all the crazy bleeding
edge development stuff in my home directory. So
brew is tech is pretty much a
rolling Linux distribution. It gives you the latest
and greatest of everything. So it's like, I
like that setup.
So it's like my home directory, latest and
greatest, the host, super stable.
And this is, like, why I also kind
of appreciate, like, Silverblue.
And and because, like, Silverblue or what, like,
Bluefin is doing like, they're kind of doing
this, you like, implicitly to a certain degree
where it's like, the host and the applications
are really completely different distributions. Because flat pack
brings in its own distribution.
But
but the so the so the way I
do things is, like, I have this this
is actually it's XFCE, but you can see
there's, like, nothing. Like, I don't I don't
like
I don't have a,
like, a dock.
I don't have a start menu equivalent thing
or whatever. It's like, all I ever do
is if I wanna run something,
I can run I hit, like, you know,
hot keys,
and, basically, I can launch things. This is
just built into XSD. So if I wanna
start an application, I can do it that
way. But the vast majority of the time,
I launch things from the from the terminal
or whatever.
I'm a very basic user in terms of,
like, I don't do fancy like
like, the way I do terminals is I
just do tabs in a terminal browser. Like,
I've never got on the TMUX train.
I keep it very, very simple.
The same thing with VIM. Like, I'm a
diehard VIM user, but I don't like, I
never got on NeoVIM.
Like, I just keep like, everything's just super
basic or whatever. So it's like, all I
ever really do in Linux is, like, for
the most part, I'm running
I have a terminal. I run my IDEs,
which I use JetBrains for everything. Actually, I
think I already have it running here.
I use JetBrains
for pretty much all of my development.
And then for a browser,
I oops. Where'd that go?
Oh, yeah. It's over here on the screen.
So for a browser
let me put it over here.
I actually use Edge,
which is weird because I switched to Edge
in the last,
like, six months to a year. I switched
to Edge, and it was,
in my story, there's, like, I've I've used
Firefox forever. Like, I love Firefox. I hate
Chrome. I've always hated Chrome for the same
reason that, like, I don't like the fact
that Chrome locks down the user experience. It's
like, there's certain things you can't change. It's
not as configurable, so I love Firefox.
But
Firefox has fallen behind Chrome for for some
time now. Like, everyone develops for Chrome. So
I've always been jealous of the Chrome users
of, like, I kinda wish I could run
Chrome,
but, like, Firefox was just fit my personality
better. And then I discovered Edge,
which
this is one of the things I appreciate
about Microsoft in general is, like, they make
everything configurable.
So
I kinda get the compromise of, like it's
not as flexible as Firefox,
but they they allow you to tweak like,
the out of the box experience, I think,
with Edge is is horrific.
But they allow you to basically, like, turn
off all the features, tweak whatever you want.
There's flags. You can find some setting. And
so, like, I ended up with, like, this
is the Edge. Like, I actually like it.
So I switched to Edge. And so it's
like
so my setup is,
like, primarily,
I'm running you know, I got a a
terminal. I run IDE, and I have a
web browser. Those are the main applications I
use.
And then what I found is, like, I
don't really use any
native Linux GUI applications.
The only GUI applications I use
are all proprietary.
And it's like I just just over time,
I've just realized this or whatever. So it's
like because it's like, I'll run you know,
it's like, I've got Slack,
Zoom.
What are the other ones? Maybe Spotify,
Discord.
But, basically because, see, every single GUI application
I run is proprietary.
And, like, basically, like,
you're you'll be extremely hard pressed, and let's
see if anyone disagrees with me, to find
a Linux GUI application
that is in fact better than a Mac
or Windows equivalent.
Oops. Can I find that? No. Okay. So
so it's like so this is, like, my
kind of, like, my whole experience
is, like, primarily,
like, just in
in these these apps.
And I don't really do a lot. It's
like I just program, and I'm on Twitter.
That's, like, my life on computers, basically.
Okay.
So
so, like, this is my Linux setup.
And so you can see, like, the so
I've
I I I got into the
I see I have a a a panel
up here. This is the XFCE panel. This
is one thing I appreciate about XFCE is
it's way more configurable than people think.
Like, the out of the box experience with
XFCE is kind of, like, archaic and weird
and ugly,
but you can very easily tweak it. And
so this is the way I've done things.
And so what I do is I perfectly
I make this this panel the exact same
size as the window title, so it just
kinda blends into it. So it's super slick.
And I and I started doing this because
of Ubuntu's
Unity is I really like the way Unity
would do this is they would blend
the applications bars into the top. And so
you get, like, the amount of screen real
estate
that's that's taken by,
you know, the the bars or whatever is,
like, almost nothing.
So so I really liked this approach or
whatever. And so that's how I've been been
running, like, my XFC or whatever.
But yeah. So that's, my Linux setup, and
I'll show you the Windows one instead or
whatever. But it's like don't know if you
have any, like, questions or you or anyone.
Oh, people are asked, like, Bash or ZHS.
I'm Bash. Like, I have just such a
like, I don't understand why people like, I'm
kinda curious of, like, why people like, one,
most mapped users, as far as I know,
use ESH because it's the default. The second
reason people use ESH
is because of the the fancy
prompt command prompt. Like, you can do and
you make it look pretty. Right? But you
can see, like, this is my command prompt.
I just don't care. I don't get a
significant amount of value out of customizing that.
The the other thing, like, just kinda personalities
wise is for me is, like,
I'm really bad at organization.
Like, there's a lot of, like, Linux users
who love tiling window managers,
and they're and they're a lot more I
just feel like they're a lot more organized
in how they approach things because it's like,
oh, look. I put this app here,
and I put this one here, and they're
much more intentional.
I'm not. I'm just like, the way I
work is, like, I'm constantly, like, opening up
new
windows and creating a couple more tabs, and
I've got a couple part. So it's like,
I love the chaos
of a floating window manager.
Although I I still do things like, you
know, I can I can do tie you
know, like, various types of tiling or whatever?
Like, it's just built into XFZ. But what
I've found over time from for myself
is I don't find tiling to be valuable
most of the time.
Like, I just I don't know. I just
don't.
Because, like, the only time where, like, logically
tiling makes sense to me is development,
but I'm also a I use IDEs. Like,
I'm not like a
like, there's a whole realm. You know, it's
like Versus Code is, like, really editor plus
plus,
and so is NeoVim. It's like editor plus
plus. And and so there's a lot of
people who, like they like tiling,
but those people who like tiling tend to
gravitate also towards, like, NeoVim or or terminal
based approaches where it's like an IDE just
gives you the same thing as tiling. Right?
It's like, I have an editor here. I
have a terminal down here. If I really
want you know? So it's like, I still
wanna be, like,
used for it or whatever.
Okay.
So
alright.
I don't know. How many are, like, the
exact opposite person?
Like, 100%.
Yeah. So that's so that's the thing is
is, like that that's the thing about Linux
is, like like,
this is what kind of what I like
about it, and it's like,
this is my personality
my personality, and this setup matches my personality,
which is, like,
completely opposite. And then what I found within
the Linux community
is I actually don't know many people who
would agree with me. Within the Linux community,
it tends to go the other way of,
like, people love, like, tiling window you know,
Sutclast, like, all the like, DWM I three,
those type of things, or they love TMux.
And it's like so that's where it's like
feel like, like, I don't fit in with
the Linux users because I'm just like, no.
I don't I don't like all that, like,
geeky cool stuff,
whereas most Linux users do. It's like they
also like Mix. You know? They're like it's
like Mix is like a engineer catnip. Like,
it's just it's like, oh, it's cool.
But Yeah. I can't go more than an
hour before trying to tweak something in my
dot files, my Z shell config, my fish
config, whatever, trying new software and just
yeah. I spent 50% of my time doing
some work in Fit to Fit, and my
time just fucking around. Change So that's the
thing is, like, I
do that. Like so I'm constantly installing distributions,
trying out things, like, fooling around with that,
fooling around with Neo. Like, all of those
things I do, but I typically do those
in a virtual machine.
So I don't screw with my, like, my
because it's like I don't know. It's like,
I I gotta work. I have a boss.
I have to deliver things. So it's like,
I can't screw with my, like, my my
default setup or whatever. But, like, I'm constantly
so it's like, I've got VirtualBox, VMware, and
Vert Manager all installed on this machine because
different hypervisors seem to do a better job
with different things. And so it's like I'm
constantly running different,
like, virtualization.
I'm always trying out diff different distributions.
But this is the this is what I
stuck to. And so
I started getting interested in Windows about
well, it's been a couple years where I've
been kind of, like, theoretically
like, I've been trying to see, like, can
I move to Windows? Because I already know
I can't survive in Mac, but, like, maybe
Windows, could.
And the reason why I started to, like,
think about that is, like, the setup that
I'm showing you is, like, the setup that
I've had for over a decade.
And the reason, like, is it works. It
works extremely well for me. Like, I have
no complaint. It just works, but that's also
boring.
It's like, I want shiny new things, but,
like, whenever I try out shiny new things
in Linux, I can't find, like,
I can't find a new thing that works
for me. Like, when I started in Linux,
like, I went through these these different eras
of, like, I was using GNOME and KDE.
I spent a lot of time in Ice
WM, which is a very weird window manager.
And then I spent a significant
amount of time in enlightenment,
like e 16.
I so that was kinda like that was
the peak of my Linux coolness was, like,
e 16. But
then, like, then I found x s like,
and then I started fooling around with Unity,
and I actually liked Unity, although all of
the Linux people hated
Unity. I actually really liked it.
So I liked Unity, and I had a
weird,
like, bastardized version of it because it was
comp Compass under the under the hood. So
it's like, you could do all the cool
Compass stuff.
And so it's like a kinda sorta ran
Unity, but it was heavily tweaked with the
Compass stuff, so it was completely different.
But then Ubuntu
abandoned
Unity, which had the side effect of basically
killing Compass.
Is that how you say it, Hayden? I
don't know how you say yeah. Yeah. It's
like
had the side effect of basically killing that
project.
So then I was abandoned. I was like,
well, crap. What am I gonna do going
forward? And then so that's why I ended
up switching to XFC. But but I've been
basically stuck on x x so I spent
all this time, like, switching my desktop environment.
Well, once I found XFCE,
and it's worked so well for me, it,
like, kinda set the bar so high that
whenever I try something else, it's just not
as good. And then this is where my
frustration with the Linux community now comes in.
It's like is the fact that, like, whenever
things get to the point where they're like,
oh, it's it it's almost there, they go
and rewrite it. Like, that's what will happen
with Gnome three. And then this is what's
happened with PopOS. Was like, I was following
PopOS where I'm like, PopOS is the new
thing. Like, that's what I'm gonna end up
switching to. Like, I wanna switch to PopOS
because it was it was so good. They
were doing such a good job.
And then they're like, we're gonna rewrite it,
which I'm like, fine. I understand. Gnome shell
is kind of a disaster.
So, like, fine. Rewrite the shell. But now
if you look at what the Cosmic Project
is doing is they're rewriting everything. They have
a new terminal. They have an editor. They
have a and it's just like, holy crap.
Like,
no.
Like, you're so close, and you're not like,
are you gonna get there now? So that's
where it's like, this is my frustration. It's
just just like so I have a setup
where it works extremely well, but as a
nerd, I want something new, but I can't
get something new because everything else sucks.
So it's like, I don't know what I
know what to do. So, like, that's why
I started looking at Windows where it's like,
I don't know. Maybe I can get Windows
to work.
So what so Windows is your new DE?
It is. So so let me show you.
So I'll show you. So it's like, you
know, you you've seen what my Linux environment
looks like. So now so what I've done
is oh, hopefully, this is still set up.
Is so I have this I bought this.
I started using Windows on my framework laptop,
and then I just recently bought this Surface
laptop, and it's beautiful. This is an amazing
laptop.
I'm not much of a fan of
the aluminum
because it just makes it super heavy,
but it has a very premium feel. So
it's like if you like
the feel of a MacBook, this is like
a MacBook replacement.
But the ARM processor is amazing in it.
It's so cool.
I've yet to really tap the powers of
the AI stuff, the the built in MPU.
But, anyway, so I bet so what I've
done let me see if this is working
right. Yeah. Have you done the benchmark share
on that Snapdragon chip? Like, does it actually
compete with the m,
the m three from Yeah. It Straight up
does. Straight up does. Yeah. It does. Awesome.
Pretty
much all the promises where it's like performance
wise, I think it like, there's m threes
that are faster.
Like, but for the most part, it's, like,
between m two and m three. The battery
life seems to be better than the Apple's
from all the benchmarks. My personal experience is,
like, I was on Intel devices for a
long time
or Intel chips or whatever. So, like, my
last Intel was a twelfth gen Intel, which
apparently was the best one because after
that, apparently, they've just gone to crap,
like, reliability and stuff, I guess. But so
I was on the twelfth gen Intel,
and I switched to an AMD.
The framework I have is an AMD, and
I was blown away with the AMD processor.
I'm like, this is way better than the
Intel's. It was faster. The built in GPU
is better.
The battery life sucked, though. It's it's six
hours, I get, if I'm lucky when I'm
coding.
Yeah. So it's like so, like, it was
really cool. Like, the AMD was way faster,
but the battery life sucked. Okay. So now
I switched to the Surface.
The performance between the AMD and the Surface
laptop
is, like, negative like, I don't notice any
difference. I'm guessing maybe the the the Surface
is faster,
but it's like
like, I I wasn't I didn't feel like
I was limited by the AMD, to be
honest. Like, performance wise, I didn't feel like
like, like, I got enough performance out of
it. So I didn't feel like it was
already so, like, with the Surface laptop and
the the ARM processor, like, I also don't
feel that way too. And I and I
have 64 gig of RAM. I can still
run, you know, VMs and all this other
stuff. And so I'm super impressed with performance.
But then on the flip side is the
battery glass.
So it's like it's amazing. Like, you you
can get like, if you're not coding,
you know, whatever, you can get, like,
I don't know, fifteen hours or something like
that. I don't know. I do a very
intensive
development or whatever.
And
I don't know. I I I I get
I get enough hours that I can go
through a day without without really having to
charge it
because I'm typically just sitting on a laptop.
So, yeah, the laptop I have Is this
not just fanless?
If that's another picture of my framework, the
fans are so noisy.
Yep. Oh, yeah. The frame well, the framework,
the the the it's noisy, and it's hot.
Holy crap. That that thing is hot. No.
So the surface, it's not fanless, but they
they won't turn on for the I mean,
like, they do turn on if you were
really pegging it because, like, I do
you know, it's a whatever. Was compiling the
l LLVM from scratch the other day, and
that takes, like, hour. Well, I had a
weird issue where it wouldn't. But but so
it's like, you can turn the fans on,
but they're pretty quiet. But the whole but,
generally, the device is silent and cool. It's
like it's not hot at all. It's a
really impressive laptop.
So I do have the the latest Surface.
They call it the Surface Copilot Plus PC,
which is terrible branding.
But I have the the brand new latest
one, the top of the line one, which
was, like, at 64 gig. It's, like, the
black the black, like, developer. There was a
special, like, brand new edition one or whatever.
I don't like, when I bought it when
I honestly, when I buy most laptops, I
kinda just scale everything all the way up
to the top. It's like, I want the
fastest investment.
I love that, but I'm gonna just say
all developers is that we always go for
the top of the line spec
the excuse that Go does a good job
of using all the cores in compilation.
So
although how often are you really compiling?
But that's my excuse of why I need
all the cores.
Okay. So let me show you. So I'm
gonna switch over.
So this should be on this side. Okay.
So I this is RDP. I got an
RDP set. Okay.
So I'm doing
remote desktop to that laptop so you can
see my setup. Okay. So this is what
again, so very similar setup. I use a
black background. Like, I only work in black
or very dark gray.
And so what I've like, I have a
very it's very similar minimal setup. Like, I
don't like
it's the same thing. It's like, don't like
a doc or anything like that, so I
just hide it. I never see the taskbar.
If I wanna switch between like, the I
do the same thing in Linux. It's like,
if I wanna find programs, I just alt
tab,
and then, you know, it's like if I
want that so it's like that's how I
know whatever I'm doing. Okay?
So
very minimal setup.
So when I launch terminal,
it just defaults
oh, did this shut down? Oh, yeah. It
probably shut down the
it shut down hyper the w sub out
too. It's normal. It doesn't take this long.
So
where the heck is this? Okay. So when
I launch the terminal, I just get Linux.
So it's like, I have the ex like,
I have the exact same,
like, Linux setup here.
So it's like so I just run Linux.
So now when I go and I run
so I don't I wouldn't typically click here
or whatever. But but it's like so if
I run, like I was saying, like, I
use JetBrains tools. So when I go and
I and I run I'll I'll click it
down here. When I run JetBrains here,
this
is running in limit in in WSL two.
It is not running natively on Windows. Like,
I do nothing in Windows. Like, I just
like, everything is in is in Linux.
Oh, yeah. I don't know why I did
that. So so this is, like this is
this is mind blowing to me. So this
is they're doing remote desktop. So the way
this works is they're they're running
this is running through x Wayland.
So I'm running x, which then goes through
x Wayland,
and then Wayland
they then translate Wayland to RDP,
and then they show RDP
like, so this is technically like a
like a windowless RDP screen sharing. Like, RDP
has the ability, you know, to
just do one window, like, not the whole
desktop. So it's like so the so this
is the the crazy thing is, like,
is there so many layers of madness going
on here?
But it works
like, it's surprisingly responsive and works well and
stuff. And so it's like, I'm doing my
development in here.
And it's like, I do notice if I
switch from Linux to Windows is, like, the
response time on this is slightly less. It's
not enough that it's like
it's not enough that, like, it causes a
problem,
but it's just like Linux and XFCE is
so ridiculously fast. Like, the there's just really
not you know, so, like, response time is
really fast.
So I do notice, but, like, I don't
have any so it's like so the way
I work is, like so it's like my
Windows setup here is oops. That's weird. Is
is, like it's not really so it's, like,
it's not really any different in that
I've got
I've got basically kind of the same things.
I have a terminal. I have the browser,
and, you know, and I'm using the exact
same edge setup or whatever. So it's, like,
the exact same experience, but I happen to
be in in Windows. And, like, what I
was saying before is, like, GUI apps that
I run, they tend to all be proprietary
things.
So all of all of those same apps
that I ran in Linux, the exact same
apps apps
exist in Windows,
but they happen to work better. But it's
the exact same user experience and everything. So
so oh, yeah. And then and then I
set up this is this
is PowerToys,
PowerRun.
This is how I run most everything in
in in so it's, like, in in,
let's see, in the what I was showing
with
in in XFCE,
I use, like, these little launcher things, which
are ugly and but they're functional.
But in Windows, basically, I use the PowerChoice
run or whatever. So
so I can run, you know, whatever. So,
like, Slack, this you know, whatever. It's the
same thing everyone has.
So so the thing is it's like it's
like, yes. This is technically Windows,
but it's like, I never leave I never
leave Linux. And and the other the other
thing is so let me show. It's like,
I have this kind of this setup where
I run sync things
that's
syncing basically, like, my source directory. This is
a weird arbitrary bins. And then, actually, my
my bash,
I put all my, like, dot files in
here, and that's the way I manage them
or whatever. But so I have synced things
that are syncing these files back and forth.
So I develop on on my desktop in
Linux, and then I just switch over to
Windows,
and I just pick up where I left
off. Like, because everything is just syncing back
and forth. And so it's like so this
is thing. It's like, I've been blown away
at, like
at that, like
I
because, like, I really like my XFCE setup
that, like, I mimic the exact same thing
in Windows,
and I still get Linux. And, like and
the cool thing about WSL two is, like,
it's very open, the whole platform, where it's
like, if I wanna do crazy weird things,
like compile a custom kernel and do stuff
like you can do it too. Like, they
don't lock down anything. Like, it's all open.
It's surprisingly
open.
So it's like, I can so it's like,
my brain doesn't really know that it's Windows,
and things just generally work better.
And it's like so I don't know. So,
like, that's that's this is, like, the setup
that that I that I use or whatever.
And I don't know. I'm I'm pretty darn
happy with the with the Windows. So it's
like, I'll probably stick with this where it's
like, I have Linux on the desktop and
Windows on the laptop
because from a laptop perspective, it just works
significantly better. Like, I'll give you, like, another
example of something that drives me nuts. It's
like full disk encryption. On a laptop, I
want full disk encryption because, like, I use
it for work. It's a good security thing
or whatever.
Full disk encryption in Linux drives me nuts.
Like, it because, like, it never, like, there's
always weird caveats and issues.
So you can do, like, the full disk
encryption,
which which then Linux will require you to
type a password on the boot manager,
or you can do the, like, the home
directory encryption,
which is integrated with the login, but then
there's other trade offs of performance and whatnot
and what EcryptFS
or whatever the current thing is. I I
haven't been following it for a while. I
don't know what the current way people are
encrypting things. But, like, in Windows and Mac,
it's like you just flip the setting, and
it works.
It's like it's just on.
Like so those are the things that, like,
I like about, like, being like, in the
Windows, there's, like
there's all these things that that just kind
of work that you forgot about in the
Linux land. Like, I really like biometric login.
So it's like that Surface laptop just does
face ID. I open it up. It scans
my face. I'm logged in. I never type
my password. Like, I like fingerprint, and I
try to use it in Linux, but it
sucks most of the time.
But it's like those things, they just work.
Like, they just work. And so it's like
I I don't know. So
Are you using Yeah.
Sorry. How do you go? Are you using
systemd and WSO?
Yes. Because, like, you just can't avoid it.
So
I hate it.
You can see, like I don't even know
why I have Snap.
Oh, what am I doing? Like, man, I
feel bad. I almost always uninstall Snap, but
there's
oh, I know why. I was trying to
do something with Chromium, and I
I I found out that, like
because this is an ARM laptop
so Windows on ARM works surprisingly well. You
very don't really notice that you're using ARM,
except for gaming. Gaming kinda sucks. But Linux
on ARM, you run more issues. And so,
specifically, the issue I found out when I
switched to this is there's, like, no upstream
support for browsers in Linux.
So the majority of the time, I'm running
the browser natively in Windows,
but I have use cases where I need
to run a browser in Linux. And so,
like, that sucks. There's no upstream
ARM
64 browsers
that I'm aware of. You have to install
open source stuff, and then then you have
all other issues.
Yeah. Google Google Chrome for ARM, I think,
is in beta.
For for oh, really?
Yeah. I'll check that out because, like I
said, I would've for what because I was
trying to do browser automation type stuff. And
so for browser automation, Chrome is actually the
desirable thing, but I couldn't even find Chrome.
But maybe maybe if I went to the
beta or developer channel or something like that
because I couldn't find it. But Yeah. But,
yeah, I do run
system d,
which is annoying,
but not really. Because, like, the thing is
is, like, as much as I complain about
system d,
like
like, all my complaints about system d are
more of, like, I just think it's a
terrible architecture and design. But, functionally, it works.
Like,
it works. And and and and the thing
is, like, if you if you actually, like,
drink the Kool Aid on system d and
go 100% in on system d, it's a
pretty slick system.
It's just like
as, like, a grumpy old Unix user,
it's
different.
You know? So it's like it's hard to
accept.
But it
but it you know, whatever. It works. So,
like, it doesn't really cause much problems running
system d because system d is really lightweight
in general. The biggest issue
I ran into, but
was I I got into some weird
for some reason, system d was trying to
manage my DNS,
which was, like, the worst thing ever.
But
but I fixed that or whatever. So
yeah. Oh, yeah. And I run I just
I run Docker just directly in WSL. I
don't use Docker for desktop. I don't understand
the value of it on Window. Like, I
just run Docker. So it's like whatever.
But yeah. So it's like with WSL too,
it's like you can do Docker and Kubernetes
and all your fancy stuff. Like, I was
I was chatting with someone recently on Twitter
about, like well, I went through, like, this
short phase where I was trying to get
Chrome OS to work. And so I have
a Pixelbook, and I have, like, a high
end Pixelbook.
I was trying to get Chrome OS to
work because I look because I was so
excited about what they were doing with Crostini,
which is their equivalent of WSL. It's like
Linux inside of Chrome OS.
But they totally botched it because they locked
it down. Like, you cannot
screw with any of the Linux stuff. So
they don't even allow real root,
which just so it's like you can't run
Kubernetes
inside of the Linux
that's on Chrome OS,
whereas on WSL two, they do. And so,
like like, those things just drive me nuts.
Said, why'd you lock it down? But, anyways
so it's like, I was really hopeful for
Chrome OS because I really like the stuff
they're doing. It's like, if you wanna see,
like,
the most bleeding edge crazy
Linux stuff,
Chrome OS is doing it. Like, they have
like, the stuff they do with the kernel
and the security stuff is, like, mind blowingly
cool,
yet they screwed up the Linux user experience,
which irritated
me.
Yeah. In 2020, I tried to go full
Chrome OS,
and I had nothing but pain with Christina.
It's a good idea, but it was frustrating
because Chrome OS is Linux. But then to
do Linux, I have to put it through
a virtual machine where
the the there was not even any GPU
support for, like, graphical apps or running Versus
code, which is Yeah. Relatively slow. It was
really frustrating. But I I love the idea
of going all in on Chrome OS. And
I don't think I've ever really fixed that
performance, at least not to my knowledge.
And this is the weird thing is just,
like, some of the best
some of the best uses of Linux are
from the proprietary people, which is weird. So
it's like because you look at, like, the
cool stuff that Chrome OS or Android does
with Linux. And then, like, if you look
at WSL, like, the stuff they're doing with
WSLG,
because they have GPU pass through support too,
which is amazing. They're like, it's really geeky
cool, like, the way they're doing the pass
through support
and stuff. And then, like, on macOS,
the way they did, like, the
they they have support for within an ARM
VM. You can
what is it? You can run x 86
code through Rosetta.
Like, they do some so it's like they're
like, some of the coolest stuff is actually
capping with the way, like, the kind of
the proprietary people are are integrating with it.
Yeah.
It's a pretty compelling setup.
Like, I may
I I don't know if I could bring
myself to do it, but I'm tempted to
just for force myself on Windows 11 for
a little bit just because I want that
that kind of vertical integration where things do
just work. That's what I miss the most
about Mac is that
the same container's
up with Docker Desktop,
but you can get around that with with
other things. But things just worked.
And if I don't like it, because I
feel like I'm it's like a it's like
a thousand paper cuts. Like, nothing is gonna,
like, scare me away, but actually, it would
be nice to have a day without those
paper cuts. But but when you think about
the things those paper cuts that you run
into are, like they're not the core thing
that you're using Linux. Like, well, I mean,
I don't know. Whatever. If you if you
just enjoy all the but it's, like, it's
it's all these, like, kind of tangential
little things, audio, screen sharing,
you know, sleep, wake, Bluetooth.
Like, screw Bluetooth. It just never works. I've
just never ever gotten Bluetooth to work well
in Linux,
which is ironic because the the entire, like,
Android Bluetooth stack is should be written in
maybe they have a custom stack. Maybe that's
what it is. I don't I don't know.
But but when because I'm I'm kinda like,
I'm at the point, like so it's like,
actively I, like, actively deter people away from
from Linux.
But, like because I don't try like, it's
just a this, like, personal thing where it's
like, I don't try to sell people. I'm
like, look. You should use my setup.
But I am curious of, like,
specific you know, it's like, for someone who,
like, just wants things just to work, it's
like
it's like, why would you not try WSL
two? Because, like because you think about it
from this perspective is is most people are
on macOS.
And so like, most developers are on macOS.
And what macOS did was, like, they gave
you a terminal that's not Linux, but it's
pretty darn close to Linux. And then the
the the the the community bridge the gap
with Brew and whatnot and brought all the
Linux ecosystem
to the, you know, Bock or whatever
Darwin
stuff.
So it's like so you're getting this thing
where it's like, was fully proprietary OS
and then
a terminal which is close to Linux but
not exactly Linux, but you would most likely
prefer to run a Linux terminal.
Whereas Windows gives you kind of the same
thing. But I think a lot of people
have just, Windows PTSD.
It's just, like, twenty years of crap, and
especially if you live through, like, Vista
or Windows eight,
which were just garbage you know, like, those
things where they just really screwed it up.
But, like, seven I think seven and eleven
have been good. Like,
10 was alright, but I really like Windows
11.
I think my challenge would be the lack
of automation. I know they've got one get
now, so, like, it's kinda like their version
of. So
this is actually so this is one thing
that I've actually come to appreciate and like
is I use this this program called UniGit.
So
when it comes to Windows, the only way
I install anything in Windows is through UniGit.
And so you can go and you can
search for whatever crap you want, like Steam.
So
and it will find it. And what this
is doing is it's going across all the
different ecosystems of Wingate, Chocolatey,
Scoop. I have some turned off because I
pretty much only care about Wingate and Chocolatey.
But and so what I do is, like,
I'll just pick the ones that are from
Wingate. So then the cool thing is is
this
I install everything through this, and then it's
set up
to auto update. So in the background, like,
you can see, like, this weather there's errors.
There's there it's trying to update something or
whatever.
So it
will just auto update everything in the background.
So it's just always upgrading everything. But then
it has this thing where let me see
if can find it.
I think it's documents.
Winget.
Oh, yeah. So it's basically it's backing up
all the packages that I have. So it's
like, it has this
if I open up this,
this should go into VSCode probably.
So it has this thing which has all
the packages that are installed.
So if I go over to another machine,
if I go to another machine, I just
open up UniGet and then, like, just open
up this file, and then it installs all
the same applications.
So
so the thing is this, like,
the you can you can 100
automate
the setup of a Windows machine. The
downside
is it's primarily
PowerShell,
and I don't understand PowerShell. That is madness.
It is it is so weird.
I've tried. One day, maybe I'll learn it,
but I just don't care to or whatever.
So that's what kinda sucks is if you
wanna automate, you have to use PowerShell.
Hayden, were you gonna say something?
So
UniGet is great,
and it's awesome that it pulls from the
various package managers available for Windows. But, yes,
you're bringing up Dev Home.
And Dev Home is
building out its ability to import configuration files.
They use
a methodology called desired state configuration,
DSC files.
And these are
now integrated with Winget and allow you to,
basically, not only do what UniGet does,
but
you'll be able to go even further and,
like, preset window settings and, like Yeah. Automatic
auto automatically set it. What what is that
form?
Yep.
Yeah. Do you want me to take that
one? Yeah. Go for it. Try to explain
Dev Home.
Dev Home is a
all in one tool for getting started
developing on Windows.
It's from the same team that built WSL,
terminal, PowerToys.
It lets you monitor it gives you a
dashboard for your GitHub repos,
gives you resource utilization,
allows you to create these machine configuration files,
allows you to there's a currently a feature
in beta that allows you to define
dev environment with natural language,
using
open API key.
So you can actually go ahead and say,
I'm gonna build, you know,
this node app with this and this,
and it will spin up a Docker container
with everything
preinstalled
ready to go for you.
It also has they've also migrated a number
of
tools that used to just be in power
tools over
into Dev Home. So they're now
basically
preinstalled
on Windows
through Dev Home.
So so this,
what people don't realize is, like, there's this
within Windows, there's, like there apparently seems to
be a group of developers or whatever who
kinda, like, drank the Linux Kool Aid or
whatever. It's, like, all of the cool things
that we've been doing in Linux of, like,
declarative management of setting up our machines and
stuff like that, they're they're supporting they're they're
bringing it all over to Windows,
but it's, like, it's going at the pay
like, it's like, Dev Home, when they first
announced it, was, like,
was very underwhelming,
and it's slowly getting better. And I expect
to know because, like, the problem I have
with Dev Home, the reason why I haven't
got into it is, like because I'm I'm
a super lazy person, and I and I
definitely don't wanna spend, like, a significant amount
of time trying to learn, like, Windows specific
things.
So the cool thing about that I liked
about UniGet was that, like, I can click
and install packages, and then it backs up
and restores the state.
Whereas right now in Dev Home,
the machine configuration
is
you've gotta learn this DSC thing,
and I have yet to figure this out.
Like, I like, you know, feedback for the
Windows people or whatever is, like
like, the
it seems like, I don't understand. Like, maybe
if you come from a Windows background, these
YAML files make sense to you or whatever,
but they don't
to me.
And so I don't know how to, like,
just type and create one, and then there's
no tooling to create or manage them. So
then it like, it's, like, a significant amount
of effort of trying to do this
this YAML based approach.
But, anyways but it but it is but
it is there or whatever. So it's like
this is kinda like the
the thing you know, it's like they're doing
surprisingly good things,
the the Windows team,
to do that. So it's like you could
do it. But, like
but, Hayden, but things that, like because things
that do drive me nuts is, like, when
I log in like, if I create a
new Windows machine, it's like, I've gotta reconfigure
the taskbar to be the way I want
it to. There's there's, like, a handful of
settings that I I I'll click around and
and I'll I'll tweak. Like, not a huge
amount of them. So it's like, it's not
that big of a deal because I could
do it really quickly. It's like, I know
I want this, this, and this.
But it's like, will it even manage those
things,
like taskbar settings and
It's it's getting there.
You know, the thing the interesting thing about
the team that that built WSL,
PowerToys,
Dev Home, Pseudo for Windows is that they're
most of these projects are fully open source,
and they're heavily community driven.
So
a lot most of the PowerToys
have come from the community
and
get promoted and then included in PowerToys.
And
feedback on things like are
pushing it along
quickly.
So, like, the ability to more easily create
DSD files from your current install,
that they've heard that feedback, and that's that's
being worked on. So
it you know, when these things first, like,
get announced at build, you know, you see
the first draft,
but they're really
building in the open
in contrast with,
you know, where Microsoft would spend a lot
of time and then announce it and then
say this is just it,
particularly
this team
at Microsoft.
Yeah. Like, what I'm surprised
with Microsoft is, like, the weird thing is,
like, when I started in Linux, it was
like Microsoft was the devil. Like, you hated
Microsoft. Right? Like, they were anti open source.
They were and, like and that that that
opinion has basically stuck with a lot of
Linux people, which is like but, like, the
weird thing is, like, in these days, if
you look at the companies,
Microsoft is actually the biggest,
like, contri like, they're the most
most embracing open source,
I think, of any of the companies, like,
going forward. Like, Google had a good run
where they were, like, really big into open
source,
but I don't
didn't seem like it financially really worked out
with them that it seems like the tides
are changing there.
But, like, Microsoft is, like, all in because,
like, I'm surprised at things where it's like
for example, like, they're they're like, you know,
it took Microsoft apparently a couple decades to
have a decent terminal, but they have a
decent terminal now. That's what I was showing
here.
But it's like things like
I I believe, like, terminal is completely open
source.
It is. So is sudo. So is power
toys.
Yeah. It it's like all
of the new stuff that they're doing that
I seem to care about is open source,
which I love,
because I can't stand it if I can't,
like, you know, dig in and figure out
how things work or whatever. But
but yeah. But, I mean, Microsoft
just has, this unfortunately,
they have to deal with their
legacy
of of, you know, some maybe some bad
things or people not liking them or whatever.
So
Yep. And it not just on the, like,
Windows dev experience
either, but also in the AI space.
Microsoft is constantly releasing
new AI tools. I know you have some
gripes about it, but things like the Onyx
runtime
I don't understand the ONNX. But yeah. I
but, like, the yeah. Oh.
Oh, I think we lost him.
Yeah.
He's at he's at Vienna right now. People
watching.
But, like, I this doesn't need to be,
like, a a like, we're I'm not trying
to sell everyone on Windows or whatever. But,
like but but it's, like, the the like,
I wanted to do this of, like, show
how I'm using Windows and and try to
not lose my Linux street cred.
Like, trust me. I'm still a die but
it but it's been an interesting experience for
me.
And you I think it's I think it's
just really interesting to see that workflow and
how it works because,
like I said, there are a lot of
paper cuts on Windows. Like, right now,
I'm 95%
running everything on Wayland,
but then there's always that random x 11
application that has to run through x Wayland.
Yeah. And that it looks weird. The scaling's
different.
And then there's even the fragmentation
between you know, I run
GNOME and GTK for most apps, but then
a random QT app pops up, and that
looks like dog shit too, and then I'm
fighting with that. And Oh, yeah. And I
and I'm just I I'm sorry. Like, I
I hate the UX design of GNOME apps.
I just cannot.
I think they are the most confusing. Like,
I'm a very like, I like, anyone who's
anyone who's worked with me on developing UIs
for, like, our programs or apps and stuff
like that knows how
frustrated I get with UIs.
Where where it's just like, I open it
up, and it's illogical to me. And it's
like, why? Why in the world did you
put, like like, the way GNOME does their
UX is basically, like, they just randomly throw
icons in the top bar.
It's just like random icons in the top
bar,
no description,
don't know what they do. We have no
idea why in the world they're in the
top bar,
but they're they're just there. But, anyways
But, like,
Weyland Weyland is one of those things that
irritates me too is is the fact that,
like, every time I try to use Weyland,
I run into issues.
So it's like,
you know, it's like, probably in another, like,
five years, it will they've we'll finally ironed
out everything. Like, I I think we're finally
getting there. But you but you realize, has
been in development for
over ten years, I think.
So it's like Yeah.
So so this is what you have to
get like, with Linux is, like, you gotta
be in it for the long haul because
it's, like,
you know, it's it's not gonna be good
for a couple decades.
It's, like, it's literally how it's, like, it's
literally, like, a decade for because, like, Gnome
three, for example, was it was like, they
started it, and it took about ten years
for it to get back to the same
level as GNOME two in terms functionality.
And now within the last couple of years,
like, GNOME three is actually really quite good.
Like, it's really taken off in the last
couple of years. There was some point in,
like, Fedora 38.
I I can't remember which version. There's there's
one version where it was very specifically, like,
where it's like, oh, wow. Like, gnome has
really gotten a lot better.
Yeah. I mean, I'm I I definitely think
gnome three is the way forward. KDE is
really nice. I actually like what the dumbest
version of plasma, but it's too for
me. And I like I actually like gnomes
UX with the buttons and the the the
CSD and stuff like that. Yeah. But
I'm I'm putting a lot of hope in
Cosmic right now. I'm really excited to see
what they bring out. And but is still
a huge pain point because,
you know, as Flatpak takes like, Flatpak is
secure. It is great. Is secure. It is
great. But getting the two to work together,
like, you can't have the one password desktop
speak
speak to the the CLI process when it
runs on because of all the sandbox, and
then they have to build all these different
portals. But those are coming out. It takes
five years per portal if you look at
all the issues that are open. Yeah. Yeah.
Progress is so slow.
So the the thing is because, yes, sir.
Like, the problem with kinda, like, Linux community
open source driven things is that, like,
you know, open source is it's volunteers. Like,
a real community of you know, so volunteers
are gonna work on fun shiny things. They
don't work on, like, the annoying little bugs.
So it's like that's it's like you kinda
have to have, like, a corporate
like, a paid person to then squash all
those little bugs. And so it's like that's
why you like, you know, it's like Canonical
did a decent job with, like, their thousand
paper cuts project and stuff like that of
squashing all the little annoying things.
So Cosmic, I think, has a decent chance
of becoming good because there is a financial
incentive for them to squash all those bugs.
It's like to actually, like, pay developers and
fix all those annoying little things that that
drive people nuts because they need to sell
hardware.
So it's like, I
I have a lot of hope in Cosmic.
I unfortunately think they're making all the same
mistakes that most
engineers
have done in this space,
which is basically,
you know, rewriting
things that don't need to be rewritten,
like, taking on too much. They're, like, they're
taking on so much that it scares me
that I don't understand how they're gonna succeed
because, like
yeah. You you start to realize, like,
the amount of stuff they
they need to, like, by going this route
of, like, having their own high like, their
own text editor, their own terminal, their own
whatever. It's a lot of work. It's like
Yeah. But that I think the reason they're
doing that, though, is that I just complained
about how I run GNOME and QT apps
annoy me. And they've probably came to the
same conclusion because Cosmic doesn't use GTK or
QT. They built their own
entire UI rendering
layer. Yeah. But now they're built on other
applications
to use that layer, and it's
So so this is so, you know, I
mean, I'll see how it it it turns
out because, like, basically, this is so
I like, because Canonical did the same thing
where there was, like, they're basically kind of
like, screw the community. We're gonna build our
own technology.
Like, the thing that's weird is, like, the
community seems to be much more accepting of
the way System seventy six is going about
this, whereas Canonical did it. It's probably just
personality and branding and whatnot. But so but
Canonical did basically the same thing where they're
like they're like, we're just gonna build our
own thing, and that's what, like, Unity was.
And they did Juju, and they've done a
lot of Snap, a lot of projects, but
they're just like, we're gonna do our own
thing. And so the problem that happens is
if you do your own thing
and you don't get the community on board,
the community is gonna end up destroying you.
Like, because they can always like, over a
decade or whatever, they'll continue to grow to
the point where it's like, now you're you've
you've fragmented or whatever. So, like so I
don't know what the like, I don't know
why they needed to change GTK, but I
do know on like, I can totally understand
Gnome Shell had a lot of issues. But
why GTK? Why the whole thing? Why a
text renderer?
I don't know. I mean, I'm sure there's
tech but but the problem is, like so
it's, I really hope because
System seventy six is the only company I
see in the Linux ecosystem that has any
chance of succeeding right now of, like, making
the desktop usable.
But,
like, they're they're doing all the same things
that everyone's done in the past that have
kind of failed. So it's like, whatever. I
mean, maybe they'll finally be the one that
succeeds, and I really hope they do. I
really like the, you know, the current version
of PopOS. So if they can reproduce that
with Cosmic
but I've I've I tried Cosmic about every
couple weeks or whatever because, like, they made
it ridiculously
easy to compile and run.
And it's it's got a it's it's got
a lot of bugs. It's got a lot
of bugs.
Yeah. I mean, it's still really early. I
mean, they only just added multi not multi
monitor support, but the monitors have different scaling
now, which I think is a really cool
addition because not everyone that buys the same
monitor twice if they have two or three
or whatever.
But but it's it's that typical engineer thing
where it's like, oh, I'm gonna write this
software, and you do the first eighty percent,
and then you realize, like, the next 80%
is where you spend all your time. It's
like, you you can get the vast majority
of the features that are like, oh, yeah.
Look. It's almost done. And then that that
last bit of just ironing out all of
the issues and stuff is, like, what takes
a significant amount of time. And so they've
spread themselves really thin with the amount of
stuff where it's, like, the amount of like
like, you don't realize how much effort
like like, if you look at the the
like, the notes app in
macOS.
The notes app in in Mac OS is
amazing, the amount of functionality that's in there.
Like, try doing drawing on especially on your
phone or whatever. Like so you don't realize,
like, these, like, these bigger companies, the amount
of effort in engineering they put into these
dumb side things. Microsoft's a little different with
Notepad, but they have a whole replacement for
it that's coming very soon. Right? Like, aren't
they finally replacing Notepad?
But
it's like but but the amount of effort
they put into these these little things, it's,
like, significant. And so it's like, I just
I really think they've underestimated. But, hopefully, they
prove me wrong. I mean, I want them
to prove me wrong because, like, that was
what I was hoping on. And then I
once I started trying out the alpha build,
I got really disenchanted.
Just like, oh, crap. They've got a long
way to go.
You know? Yeah. I I mean, I think
it's gonna be amazing, but it is definitely
still early.
But they're rewriting it in Rust, which gets
them a lot of kudos too. Right? So
Yeah. I I honestly
I always complain about Rust, and I'm like,
I I always, like, crap on Rust nonstop
on Twitter. But I think Rust is the
perfect replacement for the Linux user space of,
like, we have all of this legacy
GNU style c code,
which, you know, I don't think a modern
engine like, you have to be a very
unique individual if you like that style and
you wanna maintain that. Like so it's like,
I'm all for
bringing in kind of, like, new blood or
whatever and just rewrite the whole Linux user
space in Rust. It's a perfect fit
because
no other language is really a good switch
from
all this code that really kinda needs to
be c or c plus plus or whatever.
It's like, you can't do it in Go.
It just isn't it's not the right, you
know. So, Rust, I'm I'm actually all for
everyone doing all this this this stuff in
Rust. So I'm I'm like, I I love
all the the stuff that's
that people have been doing. I think you've
angered a few people by saying that System
seventy six is the only I can't remember
what your phrase was, but the only company
that stands a chance. Well, who
sat in the So Alan says that Canonical's
at their biggest head count they've ever been.
Oh, okay. Okay.
Let me let me let me defend here.
And and
so
I I think his point
was in response to, you know, the one,
Linux is just volunteers because Oh. Oh. Yeah.
Companies like Canonical,
Red Hat,
SUSE,
you know, they're investing a lot in,
you know, upstream things, system d,
GNOME,
the user experience. I mean, when I was
at Canonical and even after then, there was
an engineer who did a lot of work
upstream in Gnome
to improve performance
and and squash bugs there.
So that was his first point that that
it's all volunteers.
Yeah. And then Sure. Yeah. I mean, I
think it's a
interesting sustainability
question about whether or not 10 ish engineers
like,
should we should we generally follow
what Canonical,
Red Hat, SUSE, and others are investing in
GNOME kind of in that direction,
or should a small team break out and
and do their own thing?
And he he adds that he loves their
that they're innovating on the desktop, but it's
an interesting sustainability
question in the long term. Yeah. And and
and I think that because
I
I don't know. Like,
canonicals like, I don't understand canonicals,
like,
what's going on with the with the desktop
there because it's like,
they scaled back significantly
in terms of, like
I don't know. So, I mean, it it
Alan does Alan work for for for
for Canonical?
I think he used to. Previously did. We
worked together. Oh, no. You used to work
for him or whatever. Where it's like
you know, it's kind of like they they
they're no longer, like, leading because I don't
like, because
Ubuntu is no longer
I don't I don't really it's like Ubuntu
still has the most practical polish of, like,
because they still seem, like, hardware compatibility,
like, squash. So Ubuntu is still doing all
the grunt work,
but they don't have, like, the best out
of the box experience anymore
where other distributions have, like, start like, because
it used to be, like, Ubuntu. Like, every
new version, it was kind of, like, exciting
about how the desktop is changing. And Fedora
has really taken over that, where, like, Fedora
is now the gold standard of the, really,
the GNOME experience,
But we're I think Fedora fails is
is in of all of those tiny little,
like, kind of paper cuts that canonical addresses.
And that's why I stuck with with Ubuntu
is because for the most part, it just
works. Like, it's it's pretty hands off. You
can just stick an LTS,
you know, keep auto upgrading the system, you
know, the system packages, and and it works.
So
What what I Yeah.
And I and I don't speak for canonical.
Yeah. But what I see happening
is,
you know, Unity desktop was very popular, but
they ultimately made the economic decision
to shift and kind of follow the pack
and be more consistent with with the other
distros and then bring their
polish to that. So for example, it's not
default. It's not gonna be the same default
GNOME setup. It it still has the
dash to dock extension preinstalled.
It has its own it has a brand
new
out of box installer
that's
Flutter based, actually.
You know? And and at a certain point,
like, there's certain things that just aren't, like,
super exciting. But, like, it's got one click
active directory join when you set up a
new Oh, next. So just that. I was
I was very impressed with the active directory
join that they that I was just installing.
Because I just installed 202404
on on something or whatever. So I don't
know. You know, it's like
it's kinda weird because it's like
I I just don't get the impression,
but but maybe I'm wrong. It's like because
the there's kind of, like, no active marketing.
Like, I feel like canonical is is kinda
stopped trying to
get desktop users. Like, I just don't see
the active whereas, like, system 76 is making
a bigger deal about it or whatever. So
it's like so because, you know, like,
Linux is at a, you know, a very
small percentage of of the mark. So it's
like, how to get it to a larger
market of people.
I don't I think I I think that's
partly
just from our place as as geeks. You
know, we see systems at v six. We
see framework. But what we don't see
and, you know, you talk about Ubuntu's
kernel
support is Ubuntu
is one of the few companies
who are partnering with the hardware companies and
shipping Ubuntu certified hardware.
So while yes. Framework is great. Love system
76.
In terms of scale,
in terms of actually who's still shipping the
most
Yeah. You know, Linux workstations and laptops
through Lenovo,
through HP,
through Dell,
you know, it's it's still Ubuntu. And that's
that's where the hardware
support comes from. Is that is those is
those prerelease units,
you know,
going to Ubuntu and then enabling those and
certifying them prior to release.
But, like, I I don't see Ubuntu changing
the trajectory. I think that's, like, the it's
like,
you know, maybe it's a slow growth business
over over time or whatever. It's like, I
just don't see it changing
the land. It's just
I don't know. There's just nothing of, like,
why
why would the Linux desktop, like, more people
switch to it?
I don't know. It's it's it's a weird
like, like, at least, like
yeah. Because, I mean, there's there's kind of
zero chance that, like, Linux will ever be
super popular with a a consumer
a large consumer base because it's just, at
this point in time, like, why most people
aren't are going away from laptops. Like, a
lot of people don't even own a laptop,
so it's like why
so I don't know. I guess you can
almost look at it from a, like, a
doomsday perspective there. Like, it's a dying market
anyways, and so Ubuntu will just continue to
con to grab whatever they can out of
it, and there's just no shop for anyone.
I don't know. Well, I mean, Ubuntu is
still the default on the major clouds. You
know? It's still Oh, no. No. I mean,
that that's a whole different deal. Because, like,
that's that's why I feel like is is
that that canonical. Like, I'm not, like, pessimistic
on canonical in general. I think the desktop,
the on the lap laptop, I think because
they've clearly
you know, they they have the server side,
and I feel like canonical has put a
lot of effort into the
IoT,
you know, smart device and stuff like that,
and so they have a good business there.
Like, their ARM support like, they were always
the best for ARM support. So it's, like,
Canonical in general. I think these other areas
is, like, really it's like, I use Ubuntu
like, that's the only distribution I really
actually
use. It's like going going to the cloud,
desktop, whatever, whereas, you know, with all of
these. Yeah. Yeah. Let's tackle something that George
has brought up now. So he he said
that we've not talked about economics,
which is true. And then he also says
that we're terrible customers.
And
now you're using Windows,
which is a paid for operating system and
a ton of proprietary software of which you're
probably paying for.
But he's right. Like, where is the money
flowing into Linux? Like, I'm not paying for
GNOME. I'm not paying
for, you know, my Silver Blue install.
Like,
is is this an economic problem? Like, should
we be paying up more money for a
better Linux desktop experience?
Well, I mean, obviously, yeah, it'd be great
if people pay, but, like, the but the
thing is is nobody pays for an OS,
really. So, I mean, that's kind of the
that's the basic problem where it's like, sure.
Like, all of you can get all the
Linux nerds out there to feel guilty and
pay money or, you know, we wanna help
the world to pay money, but it doesn't
really matter because the the rest of it
like,
it's not it's not enough money. Like, the
larger market of people like, so it's like
it's a weird thing that's happened with the
entire software industry or whatever. It's like you
don't make money on software. You just don't.
Like like, there's of of course, the legacy
people, like, the the old proprietor, you know,
Oracle or whatever who are still printing money
off of software.
But, like, the majority of software development these
days is, like, you don't make money off
of it, and it's like
the and and ironically, the most challenging, difficult
the hardest technical problems you can solve in
software is all given away for free now.
It's all done in open source, and there's
zero value to it. So it's like, it's
this weird thing. It's like, well, should you
be paying for it? It's like, yeah. But,
like, nobody pays for it. So, like, why
do like yeah. Enter.
No. But these guys are, like, basically it's
like the
yeah. I mean,
yeah, Valve and and Adobe.
It's like it's the thing it's like the
the same people who have always been make
making money off of software are still making
but, like, anything that's, like, new.
Yeah. I mean, I think we also have
to accept that the quality of the software
is different. Right? When I was on a
Mac, I was paying for Raycast, which is
probably the greatest launcher and the only piece
of software I generally miss
from my Mac. And I paid for monthly
subscription.
And I look at my Linux app, and
I don't think there's any software I'd probably
even pay for just because they're not as
good. And I don't know if that's because
they're all contributed to by volunteers and time
is limited and such. Yeah. But nobody's ever
entered, like, the actual
proprietary software thing. So I think you're right
to say there's no money in software, especially
in a Linux ecosystem, but it doesn't mean
that there shouldn't be longer term.
The there's this this kinda sad, like, reality
with open source stuff where it's like people
spend a lot of time in open source
developing.
And so they're like, well, I should be
compensated for that time. So they kind of
they said, look. My time should be worth
this much. Therefore, you should be paying for
that. But, like, unfortunately, it's like that's not
the way, like,
I don't know, economics works or whatever. It's
like, what you'll find is if you take
your software that you've been giving away from
free,
like, make it proprietary and say you have
to pay $5 and see how many people
will pay for it. Not many people will
will pay for it because they don't value
it. That's unfortunate. Like, that's the unfortunate reality
is, like, people will use software that's free,
but as soon as you have to pay
for it, like, they they they won't. And
but it really does come down to the
fact that they don't get enough value out
of it to pay for it. Well
yeah. And the
thing is is
right now,
the
number one customer who pays for Linux, even
on Linux on the desktop, is enterprise.
And
as long as that continues,
with maybe the exception of, like, system 76,
as long as that continues, it's going to
be their issues that get prioritized.
Yeah. I mean, that's just it. That's just
it. So,
you know, when I started
Penguin Linux, which was
bespoke WSL distro for WSL,
you know,
we we charged 5. I think the
it's now 10.
But we basically offered a social contract with
our customers where, yes, we know you could
go download
Debian or Ubuntu for free,
but give us $510
for this.
We give you best effort support,
and, you know, we we make all these
cool customizations optimized for WSL. This was also
WSL one days when you needed a lot
of those. And,
basically, we were committed
to
what the community
wanted who'd who'd who'd paid for it. And
we were able to do that by putting
it in the Microsoft Store.
And as Alan brings up, right now, there's
really no way to do that for Linux
end user software.
There's there's I mean, it's just
not possible.
Yeah. With the Mac, you've got the you've
got the Mac App Store, Windows you've got
the Windows App Store at Linux. I know
George says that they're working on FlatHub support
and payments. But
Yeah. But, like but it's it's very tricky
of,
because it's,
because
if you build up an open source software
and then you accept accept
expect people to pay after the fact, like,
it's like it's been open source, and then
that like, people most likely won't pay. You
know, it's like, it works better if, like,
you know, it's like you're kind of charging
from day one. You've you set that expert.
I don't know. It's like charging for open
source software is extremely difficult. I mean, it's
that's why, like, the startup I'm currently in,
the startup previously did, we we do open
source software. Like, I love open source.
But selling it is it's a very
difficult,
tricky thing.
Yeah.
I don't know. Like, I I I don't
think because it's, like, going back to, like,
what I was saying before is, like, why
I thought, like, set system 76 had, like,
the best chance or whatever is, like the
reason why I I I put most of
is because they're selling hardware.
It's like that's that's the biggest thing. But,
you know, maybe Canonical can do it with
partnering with people, but it's still there's this
weird thing that I don't think I don't
think the hardware vendors are incentivized enough to
make like, they're kind of too much in
bed with with Windows
that I don't know. Maybe it's not true.
But, like, I don't know if things that
are really incentivized enough to make Linux good
on their devices.
But ThinkPads, they do it. Like, ThinkPads are
amazing with Linux.
Yeah. And and there's there's some, you know,
$4,050,000
dollar, you know, ML workstation that from Lenovo
that Oh. Come with Ubuntu.
So, I mean, it it goes all
the way up up up the market. So
Yeah. But it's a tough it's a tough
it's a really tough business. So I definitely
would not wanna be in. Yeah. I mean,
I worked at SUSE for a while or
whatever. It's, like, just seeing, like, the whole
Linux business. It's a very it's a tough
business.
It's
because, like, the most most Linux
companies, what they're selling is
certification.
It's hardware certification or compliance,
like, with with that's that's really what they're
selling.
It's it's,
you know, because that's what people require you
know, so they're, like, not really selling the
the software because it's all open source and
commoditized and freely available, but, like, companies need
the certification and stuff or whatever. You know?
And it yeah. It's a it's a weird
thing.
Yeah. The support, the FIPS
certification
Oh, yeah. Those kind of thing. Yeah.
It's like that's what people end up paying
for.
But
yeah.
I don't know.
What's been Well It's been fun. I'm sure
it pissed off enough people.
Yeah. We've gone way over what we intended
to do, but, you know, I think we've
had some good discussions.
Yeah. There's there's a lot of work that
needs to go for Linux to have that
year of of the desktop. I think you
should abandon your AI project and go build
a software store for for Linux now.
This is this is the thing. It's like,
I often think about, you know, it's like
if I had Russian cosmonaut money, would I
would I, like,
defy like, because I love the Linux desktop,
and I would love to fix it. I
would love to, like but it's like, is
it even worthwhile? I don't know.
One one of these days.
Yeah. I think I think we'll leave it
we'll leave it there. That's just that to
be continued. So I slip back in, like,
six months or twelve months and and and
see if things have improved. But Yeah. And
I I'll tell you how terrible Windows is,
and now I'm back on,
you know, I'm
sure we'll get a tweet for it in
two weeks when you you jump back onto
Windows or Linux or Mac or whatever. Yeah.
Do have a rotation. So it's We could
do we could do a follow-up the follow-up
on Android
and iOS. It's it's all the same
it's like all the same things there.
Right. Awesome. Oh, well, thank you both for
joining me. It's been an absolute pleasure.
Thank you for everyone on the chat for
your contributions.
Al and George, I'll reach out to you.
I'm sure we should set up another session.
You know what to share as well. Of
course. Yeah.
I'd love I'd love to get in have
a conversation with them about because I I
really love what he's doing and, like, their
their their stuff there.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'll catch you all later. Have good day.
Bye.